>>Jill Levine: At Normal Park,
we believe that learning should
not be bound by the front
and back covers of a textbook or
the four walls of our building.
We did a lot of thinking
to figure out,
what is a museum magnet school?
Every week, our students go
to a museum or on some type
of learning expedition.
That's where the learning
really comes to life.
As a museum school, we're
connected with seven museums.
We have a contract
with the museums
which basically gives
us unlimited access
on a certain day of the week.
Every student has a museum
passport, so they can go
for free back to the museums on
the weekends or in the evenings
and then, the museum
educators plan
with our teachers
once each quarter.
We really try to figure out
how we can enhance the content
learning that's going
on in the classroom
by teaching art concepts
at the same time.
We opened the school
in 2002, and in 2005,
we were named the top
magnet school in the nation
by Magnet Schools of America.
We've received the John F.
Kennedy School of Distinction
in Arts Education, which
is a national award.
And we've been designated as a
State Reward School in Tennessee
for having some of the highest
test scores in the state.
The Normal Park way is basically
a list of strategies that we use
that everyone on the faculty
agrees these things are best
practices for students.
So, it includes exhibit
building,
planning with understanding
by design, guided reading,
teaching problem-solving in
math using the Singapore math
model-drawing approach.
It includes collaboration
and organization.
The two keys to our success as
a school in our transformation
and then our ongoing
success in terms
of student achievement are, one,
that I hire the best
possible teachers and, two,
that there's this consistency
of instructional program,
that what happens in a
first-grade classroom happens
in a third-grade
classroom and happens
in a seventh-grade classroom.
Our whole curriculum for science
and social studies is organized
into nine-week blocks that
we refer to as modules.
To plan those modules, we use
"understanding by design."
People often refer to
this as backward planning.
We first think about
the big ideas, you know,
what do students have to
know and be able to do,
and then what are the big
understandings that can carry
over from one content
area to another?
So, for example, where you
live affects how you live.
Then they look at, how are
we going to assess that?
For us at a museum
magnet school,
those assessments
are our exhibits
and also the travel journals.
Every nine weeks, the whole
school turns into a museum.
The halls will be filled
with parents and children
who are all here to celebrate
what their children have
accomplished in the past nine
weeks, the students' writing,
the students' problem-solving,
the students' thinking,
and it really is a
great way for students
to share their learning
with their parents.